peu
[Musique]
voilà bien des années déjà que l'auteur
de ce livre fort c'est à regret de
parler de lui est absente paris
il n'a pas besoin de dire qu'il aime
baril paris est la ville natale de son
esprit
[Musique]
tant qu'on va et vient dans le pays
natal on s'imagine que ces rues où sont
à différentes que ces fenêtres sétoise
et ses portes nous poussons de rien que
ces maisons où l'on n'entre pas sont
inutiles et que c'est pas vu nous on
marche sont des pierres plus tard quand
on n'y est plus on s'aperçoit que ces
rues vous sont chers que c'est toi ses
fenêtres et ses portes vous manque que
ces murailles vous sont nécessaires et
qu'on a laissé de ses entrailles de son
sang et de son coeur dans ces pavés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
car paris exprime le mans paris et d'un
total
paris et le plafond du genre humain qui
voit paris troyes bar le dessus de toute
l'histoire avec du ciel et des
constellations dans les intervalles pas
rien capitole l'hôtel de ville 1
parthénon notre dame un monta vente à le
produire saint-antoine un panthéon le
panthéon paris est synonyme de cosmos
paris athènes rome 6 marie jérusalem
pantin
[Musique]
1831 louis philippe 1er roi des français
règne depuis un an et déjà la révolte
gronde
quelque chose de terrible couvent on
entrevoit les linéaments encore peu
distincts et mal éclairé d'une
révolution possible la france regarde
paris paris regarde le faubourg
saint-antoine nos doctrines sont
entravés nos proclamation sont déchirés
noah fischer sondes étaient jetés en
prison
mais la crise qui vient d'arriver dans
le coton à convertir notre cause
beaucoup de modérer et l'avenir des
peuples s'élabore dans nos rangs obscur
citoyens les termes sont clairement
posée action réaction révolution contre
révolution pour le peuple contre peuple
c'est la question il n'y en a pas
d'autres citoyens
dispersez vous dans le cal
[Applaudissements]
tu va mouiller et à poudre carnage non
mais chez moi j'ai 500 cartouches et 24
heures et fusils allez viens te demande
pas si moi je ne demande pas avant
quinze jours on sera en parallèle avec
le gouvernement avec renzo milan on peut
se mettre en face non il cross le
gouvernement écoute dans les 300 ce
qu'on pourrait faire on pourrait même
qui sous chacun pour 150 francs on
pourrait fabriquer la poudre et des
balles lors de la nuit pour fabriquer
les cartouches
alors tant il est une tendance que l'on
discute la chose pour se battre pour
rester tranquille au premier cri
d'alarmé
tu trouveras dans la rue et tu te battre
à sans compter le nombre de tes ennemis
tu le jure compagnon je le jure tu
entends tu le connais
[Applaudissements]
je suis papou piste l'opposition de
gauche il achèterait la révolution mais
elle ne l'a pas les républicains
l'incendié des crapules
méfiez-vous des républicains citoyens
travailleuses il ya un citoyen moucheurs
[Applaudissements]
k
complot est mûr la chose et prendre mais
on n'a pas d'armée les soldats non
[Applaudissements]
marchand de vin ce qui est du la
révolution verra qui est en chef je n'en
connais pas et je n'en reconnaît pas oui
si oui nous avons un rapport de la
société des droits de l'homme et il est
daté pluviôse an 40 de l'ère
républicaine encore la société de droits
de l'homme était légale mais derrière il
ya la société d'action les impatients et
puis le comité d'organisation des
municipalités l'association pour la
liberté de la presse
l'association pour les libertés
individuelles la société des ouvriers
égalité qui se divise en 3 d égalitaire
les communistes et les réformistes et
enfin l'armée des basques y ait une
espèce de kort mai organisés
militairement quatre hommes commandés
par un caporal dix hommes par un sergent
20 par un sous-lieutenant 40 un
lieutenant mais jamais plus de cinq
hommes qui se connaissent et le
mouvement s'étend en province lyon
nantes lille et marseille sont touchés
c'est grâce à tous ces gens crient abalo
philippe vive la république
souvenez-vous le 93 serre ce sont les
mêmes merci monsieur le préfet merci
monsieur le maréchal
merci messieurs
la révolution de 1830 cette invite
arrêté sitôt qu'une révolution a fait
côte
les habiles d'épaisses l'échouement les
habiles dans notre société se sont
donnés à eux mêmes le qualificatif d'
homme d'état si bien que ce mot homme
d'état a fini par être un peu un mot
d'argot et les habiles disent les
révolutions comme 1830 sont des artères
coupé il faut une prompte ligature il
faut raffermir l'état qui arrête les
révolutions à mi-côte la bourgeoisie
pourquoi parce que la bourgeoisie c'est
l'intérêt arrivé à satisfaction le
bourgeois c'est l'homme qui a maintenant
le temps de s'asseoir
il fallait à la bourgeoisie un homme qui
expriment à ce mot halte
cet homme était tout trouvé il
s'appelait louis philippe d'orléans la
chambre des pairs fils louis philippe
roy tout cela a été fait en dehors du
droit absolu le droit cria je proteste
les choses redoutables
il rentra dans l'ombre oui je veux que
nous appelions notre groupe les amis de
la bce à baisser alors vous avez le
temps de rire messieurs et calembours
c'est quelquefois grave en qualité et
qui a reste pas les rois que droit
suprême on les revoit pur bonheur des
plus grosses erreurs sont le progrès le
bien soit innocent mais j'en veux pas
moi
ne serait ce qu'au point de vue
économique on n'a pas le droit gratis et
l'aigle l'aigle écoute savent cherté du
roi dette publique à la mort de françois
1er trente mille livres à la mort de
louis xiv 2 milliards 600 millions
alors vous pensez si le roi arrête quand
fera qu moyen de savoir où on en met sur
qui on peut compter maintenant et il ne
s'agit pas de remettre ce travail là
demain révolutionnaires doivent toujours
être pressé le progrès n'a pas de temps
à perdre
confer ac tu verras les polytechniciens
c'est l'argent sorti aujourd'hui
mercredi failli n'est ce pas vous verrez
cela glaciaire confère tu m'as promis
d'aller à puce barre elle visitera
l'estrade prouvèrent les maçons ça ne va
plus très bien il faut des nouvelles de
là je dois neil jolie dupuytren l'aigle
au palais tu discutera avec les
stagiaires bon moi je me charge du reste
[Musique]
dragueur pourquoi montparnasse l'arrière
du maine et des marbriers dépeindre des
ateliers de sculpture c'est une famille
enthousiasme est sujette à
refroidissement
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont plus quelques
temps ils s'éteignent faudra aller leur
parler et ferme
ils mangent série cheveux entre midi et
une heure je suis l'homme
pourquoi pas complètement quelque chose
toi j'en ai la dengue ambitions mais on
te croit rien si je crois en toi je leur
à ce grand mot celle ci a été bâti du
vin cuvée tous à la télé je suis là bas
je suis capable de traverser la place à
michel de prendre la rue monsieur le
prince la rue de vaugirard lé la rue
d'assas tourner rue du cherche midi par
ses conseils de guerre d'arrivée
barrière du maine d'entrée sherif fais
j'en suis capable
mes souvenirs sont capables et tu serais
leur parler moi quand je me mets ce fut
terrible constitution de l'an 2 la
liberté d'un citoyen finit où la liberté
d'un autre citoyen commence je suis un
peu hébertistes et ouais tu sois sérieux
je suis farouche rouge bon grand-père
tuera barrière lui-même
dans les salons ultra de ce temps là la
parole était à peine un souffle tout
cela avait l'air d'avoir vécu il ya
longtemps et de s'obstiner contre le
sépulcre conserver conservation
conservateurs s'étaient oblique ses
nerfs l'aigle de ces salles on
s'appelait monsieur gilles normand il
avait 81 ans libéré sur la retirer de la
garde nationale
ces élèves de l'école de droit et de
médecine et morveux sur la place du
panthéon et aux vertus magiques là qu'on
va la bm je parierais tout ce qu'on
voudra un million contre un fish qu'il
n'y aura la caulerpa justice et des
forces à libérer sur républicain chez
gallerias je ne fais qu'un seul n'est
qu'un seul ou schwarz suis bien de mon
avis marius tient sur faire votre petit
fils a l'air bien extrait depuis
quelques temps quelques clients
[Musique]
ah oui c'est ma rue j'ai panda roux suis
médias il anime également je n'ai pas
comme un smartphone maurice et vous
lirez jasmin reflux que je ne verrai
jamais même que dina cinq heures après
quoi ma porte est ouverte qui veut le
voir rien après ça mais mon père
monsieur connaît qu'un bon royalistes
alors elmont entretiendra le sa
révérence envers la dynastie après cinq
heures du soir à un malus retirez vous
retiendrez vous
[Applaudissements]
marius peur de me pourrir non pourquoi
avoir trop peur mais je ne connais pas
mal et pas qu'il est malade
tout le monde part de vos matin je crois
qu'il y ait encore des fontaines une
voiture pris part à six heures et qui
arrive le soir le sommer dans dire
il a épousé ma fille les l'on aime entre
filles de marie thérèse d'autriche
elle vient d'épouser un pour la partie
front les accidents qui arrivent dans
les familles sort
[Musique]
le super merci c'est ici moi je lui
parlais je suis son fils il m'attend
[Musique]
c'est vous le fils
oui vous avez cinq minutes trop tard il
a voulu se lever à l'est vers vous alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
c'est un monsieur pour mercier que je
leur dois parler oui
c'est ce que je me suis dit j'étais un
enterrement monsieur en vous voyant je
me suis dit que vous deviez être le fils
j'étais un ami de votre père monsieur
monsieur madoff le marguillier de la
paroisse me permettez vous de vous
accompagner l'instant
peut être allez vous m'en vouloir
monsieur mais il faut que je vous dise
votre père vous aimait beaucoup mais on
ne peut pas savoir oui il m'avait
raconté la situation votre grand père
votre tante qui est si riche que vous
seriez déshérités c'est une gare des et
qu'on vous écarter de lui pour des
raisons politiques n'est ce pas enfin
certainement jeu j'approuve rice
opinions politiques mais mon dieu parce
qu'un homme était colonel à 21,9
ce n'est pas un monstre tout de même ben
voila je vous salue monsieur pro merci
au revoir monsieur monsieur j'ai trouvé
ce que je vais vous dire pendant des
années tout les voit régulièrement
il est allé à paris pour vous voir à
saint roch c'est bien votre paroisse est
ce pas oui alors quand on vous met à la
messe il se cachait derrière une colonne
pour pouvoir regarder disant monsieur
vous remercie pour les bois je voudrais
que vous sachiez cela enfin monsieur
merci
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
marius tempère de partir mon père ah oui
mais si monsieur j'ai arrangé une partie
de chasse avec quelques amis voulez-vous
me permettre de m'absenter trois jours
car je suis tu veux voir un match au
moustoir
merci c'est bien ce que je pensais il
décochait matricide il il tombe amoureux
enfin trois fois on à moi qui fois mois
à jonage eux on ne m'aurait pas envie
d'un trimestre la maison mais je vous
assure ma tante reid une on nous change
de garnison nous étions à melun on nous
met à gaillon et de deux je me dis
puisqu'il faut passer par paris à
londres voir ma tante je fais mener mon
cheval par mon brevet je prends la
diligence et de 3 à la correspondance de
paris sur la feuille de la diligence des
andelys
je vois un nom marius pour merci à c'est
pas un gars sont rangés comme toi c'est
marius séducteur que ça ne te connais
pas non et puis je vais te dire marié
fait des absences des couches à une
fillette a évidemment et nous aimerions
savoir tu comprends on voudrait que
voilà la tâche de voir la fillette est
écrit nous l'histoire s'amusera grand
père
il
oui mon père ce n'est peut-être pas la
peine de faire fouiller sa chambre
nerius a laissé moi la paix voulez-vous
lacroix voulait pas rester là à me
regarder le carré
à
voilà
pour monfils
l'empereur m'a fait baron sur le champ
de bataille de waterloo puisque la
restauration me conteste ce titre que
j'ai payé de mon sang en suisse le
prendre un et le portera
quelle leçon dire qu'il en sort indigne
en cette même bataille de waterloo
un sergent m'a sauvé la vie il s'appelle
thénardier
si monfils se rencontrent il fera
thénardier tout le bien qu'il pourra
colonel baron pour merci pour tes
scénique
mais emporté sa lippe
[Musique]
je
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
cela veut dire que j'ai un père ton père
chez moi mon père c'était un homme
humble héroïque qui a servi la
république et la france qui a été grand
dans la plus grande histoire que les ai
jamais fait qu a vécu 25 ans le jour
sous la mitraille et les bals la nuit
dans la neige et la pluie qui était bien
c'est 20 fois tellement dans l'oubli et
l'abandon mais qui n'avait qu'un seul
temps c'était trop aimer son pays son
fils sait pas qui était ton père je ne
vais pas le savoir je ne sais pas je
n'en sais rien mais ce que je sais c'est
qu'il n'ya jamais du coup les misérables
parmi ces longs là que c'était tous des
cueilleuses à 500 et des voleurs jeudi
tous douce je ne connais personne je dis
tous vous des brigands qui on survit
robespierre tous des lâches qui se sont
sauvés qu'avant les prussiens et les
anglais en matière l'eau tout mon temps
marius tous trompés rien de fou je ne
peux rien tant pis pour vous à bas les
bourbons et ce gros cochon de louis
xviii
un barreau comme marius bourgeois comme
moi ne peuvent rester sous le même toit
attendre
[Rires]
ils ont jailli tu es toujours brouillé
avec sais qui je veux dire le boude
avait une passion ce cruel
[Applaudissements]
ta place et de la plante et là c'est la
dure et elle s'appelle musique et à
bassam est complétée à temps l'aigle
superbe qualité des petits pieds petites
mains se mettant bien attend du monde
hui je suis fou nous c'est simple non
alors mon vieux soit ligue en fait des
effets de recul à cet effet ce taux à un
pantalon de cuir de l'aisne
ça pose bon
[Applaudissements]
havas
monsieur je vous cherchez vous êtes
marius pont merci mais je ne vous
connais pas monsieur moi non plus mais
vous n'étiez pas à l'école de droit
avant-hier c'est possible et alors alors
avant-hier je suis entre à l'école de
droit par hasard on a quelquefois des
idées étranges blondeau faisait l'appel
ils sont très ridicule ans maintenant au
troisième appel manqué on voyait
l'inscription 63 ans vous commencez à
comprendre avec jours alors blondeau
vicieux à commencer par la lettre p
voisins absents l'univers était présent
blonde aux rites et triste
tout à coup ils appellent marius pour
mercy personnes
il répète marius pour mercy rien il
prend sa plume monsieur j'ai des
entrailles
je me suis dit dans un éclair voilà un
brave garçon honnête paresseux qui
cultive la grisette qui fait la cour aux
belles et qui peut-être en ce moment
chez ma maîtresse sont bons le et j'ai
répondu présent pour vous ce qui fait
que vous n'avez pas été rayée c est que
moi je l'étais blondeau a sauté sur la
lettre elle
il appelle l'aigle l'aigle l'aigle c'est
moi alors je réponds présent
alors il me dit avec la douceur du tigre
si vous êtes bon merci vous ne pouvez
pas être l'aigle ce qu'il faut bien le
dire tombe sous le sens il mariait à non
moi je suis ravi j'étais sur la pompe
d'être avocat
cette eau ratures me sauver plus de
toges plus d'effets de manche je suis
radié d'avant c'est à vous que je dois
cela monsieur pons merci et j'entends
vous faire en gants jaunes une visite de
remerciement ou demeurer vous dans ce
fief
félicitations vous avez là un loyer de
9000 francs par an vous êtes trop cheap
en fait c'est quelque chose comme ça
mais je ne sais pas vous aider et chez
moi non pardon j'ai la priorité oui je
sais je n'y a pas de mai
cochez hôtel de la porte saint jacques
donc voilà je le racheta demande est
passée à montparnasse pour voir où en
était un grand air et sculpteur c'est
vrai qu'au chez gerry cheveux barrière
du maine double si on le port de los
j'ai fait voter non mais non mais non ça
va très bien j'ai tellement de chance ou
de l'ass et de à propos vous avez des
opinions politiques
évidemment qu est ce que vous êtes
démocrate bonapartiste
nuance agree de sourire assuré de
s'imposer sûrement des rampes
j'ai 15 francs par jour
15 30 si vous voulez vous remercie et
j'ai cet habit kipre j'ai aussi cette
montre aux morts je connais a publié
alors le geste va très bien ensemble on
vous savez l'anglais
demain je connais aussi un vibreur il
édite une espèce d'encyclopédie à des
articles à traduire
mais j'apprendrais l'anglais est mais en
attendant je mangerai mon habit et mamou
vous enverrez 600 francs d'or tous les
six mois un ce buveur de sang et vous
n'entendrez jamais plus bonjour marie
simona marius et l'avocat ce marius
hilton les instructions marius n'a pas
un sou et marius refuse l'argent de la
légitimité mais écoutez tous
homme de peu de foi on est venu offrir
un marius 600 francs en or ce matin et
marius les a refusées je vais arrête la
russe trois à la pauvreté salvatrice
d'ailleurs en ivoire est il pas qu'il a
parfois fait ressembler c'est beau c'est
toi donc offert un il a promené les non
non non non non monsieur quand on écrit
un vaudeville on commence d'abord par
trouver les noms et puis voyez quand on
a les noms on trouve le sujet ouais je
sais juste seul ou alors dicté bon
monsieur dream on dorion rentiers
sa fille celestini est une
après le colonel rival honni duval ça
fait un peu usé j'attends moi j'irais
plutôt bal du met et 18 juin 1815
waterloo ça fait 16 ans aujourd'hui
oui on est bien le 18 juin elle vous
remarqué que ces nombreux fatale de
bonaparte 18 brumaire louis xviii tout
le destin de l'homme est là le
commencement est talonné par la fin je
veux dire que le crime est talonné par
l'expression
[Musique]
la corse une petite île qui a fait la
france bien grande
la france a besoin d'aucune corse pour
est grande
la france est grande parce qu'elle est
la france à dieu ne plaise que je
diminue la france à sa part monde
je vous avoue m'étonner qui êtes vous je
vous entends dire bonaparte en
accentuant nus comme des royalistes
je vous préviens mon grand père fait
mieux il dit bonaparte et mais kerry et
vous si vous n'aviez pas l'empereur il
avait tout mis était complet il avait
dans la tête de cul des facultés
humaines
il faisait des codes comme justinien il
fixait comme césar il faisait l'histoire
et il écrivait ces bulletins sont d
iliad il rillettes au berceau de son
fils et le lendemain en europe les
phares et écouter les armes et se
mettait en marche des parts d'artillerie
rouler les nuées de la cavalerie
galopaient dans l'ouragan pays compet
tremblement de drones partout les
frontières du royaume s'il est sur la
carte et on sentait le wydad l'être
humain qui sortait du faux et on le
voyait lui se dressé debout sur
l'horizon avec un plan woimant dans la
main et c'était l'archange de la guerre
enfin marigot partout austerlitz iéna
wagram faire à chaque instant éclore des
constellations de victoire a donné l'
empire français pour pendant l empire
romain être la grande nation et enfin de
la grande armée vaincre foudroyé être le
peuple de l'europe ce n'est à travers
l'histoire une fanfare de titan c'est la
sublime
que peut-il y avoir de plus grand être
libre ça m'avait donné la mort et la
guerre lui quitté la mort de ma mère je
dirais en gros c'est ça reprend consacré
ton char je ne me lemaire ok j'admets
un citoyen la mer c'est la république
observez la banlieue de paris s'est
observé l'amphibie fin des arbres
commencement des toits fin de l'herbe
commencement du pavé fin des ornières
commencement des patients de là un
intérêt extraordinaire presque personne
ne connaissait lieu singulier la
glacière le mur de grenelle le
montparnasse montsouris la tombe issoire
la pierre plate de châtillon le lieu où
une plaine fait sa jonction avec une
ville est toujours empreint de séquelles
mélancolie pénétrante
quiconque a erré comme nous dans ces
solitudes il y a entrevu à l'endroit le
plus abandonnée au moment le plus
inattendu des enfants livide boueux
poudre dépenaillé hérissé qui joue à la
pioche couronnais de bleuets
ce sont les enfants des familles pauvres
le boulevard extérieur et leur milieu
respirable la banlieue leur appartient
on en voit qui mangent des cerises dans
les blés
le soir on les entend rire et la nuit
ils ne savent pas où dormir dans notre
civilisation actuelle ce n'est pas une
chose très anormal que ces fractures de
famille se vidant dans l'ombre de leurs
entrailles et ne sachant pas ce que
leurs enfants sont devenus cela
s'appelle être jetés sur le pavé de
paris
qu'est ce que tu vas faire cesser la
voix soir je rentre en ville jma au
théâtre je fais la claque mais je veux
d'abord pensé voir ma mère faubourg
saint marceau tu as encore ta mère bah
oui c'est ce qui va me dire ma mère va
me dire qu'est ce que tu viens faire ici
un voilà ce qu'elle va me dira ma mère
ça fait rien je trouve un billet moyen
duquel les gencives par la banque elle
s'allume au ses parents ayant jeté
gavroche dans la vie d'un coup de pied
il avait tout bonnement pris sa volée
c'était un garçon brouille emblème l'est
éveillé goguenard à l'air vives c'est
maladif
il riait quand on l'appelait gallopin ce
franchet quand on l'appelait voyous ils
n'avaient pas de gîtes pas de pain pas
de feu pas d'amour mais il était joyeux
lorsqu'il était libre tiens c'est
j'attends que ceux là vieille salue la
pause pour marius la vie était devenue
c'est vers l'hôtel trop cher pour sa
bourse
il avait émigré faubourg saint marceaux
où il occupait moyennant un loyer annuel
de 30 francs
un taudis sans cheminée qualifié cabinet
il gagnait 700 francs par an à faire des
traductions et à rédiger des prospectus
là dessus ils paient ces inscriptions
plutôt que d'emprunter il n'aurait pas
mangé
les quatorze joue beaucoup de temps et
une côtelettes de mouton sans manche 6
ou 6 ans mangent une tête de mon temps
[Musique]
le malheur est ce qu'à cet âge là il
ferait pas mieux de donner le bras une
jeunesse en bonnet plutôt qu'une
bibliothèque
si je me sens bien ça me sépare de
profil le 1er juin son image à viande le
deuxième ça mange la grèce et le
troisième larron gelos depuis six mois
qu'il est là j'ai pas vu de 10 fois être
pour ouvre l'avenir sans espérance labit
percée au coude le vieux chapeau qui
fait rire les filles les humiliations la
dignité refouler les basses besognes
accepter les dégoûts l'amertume
l'accablement terrible épreuve
[Musique]
bien tu crées êtes nous rentrons
déjà oui père
[Applaudissements]
beau costume chapeau 9 habits neufs et
marieuse dedans et tu vas passer un
examen que tu as l'air super quelques
mimiques au tombeau des florides toi tu
es amoureux
peut-on connaître le nom de l'heureux
crise mais n'en voyons garde le marié
cette façon bien que je joue devant une
fillette en soi puisque était cuit
marius est un brouillard il a dû
rencontrer une vapeur
adam de mario se référer chanteur est
rare qu'un sommet du loup dans network
of heracles j'ai une grande nouvelle
je t'invite à souper quoi et oui et toi
tu viens aussi l'aigle et je paie le
spectacle en dit vous avez lu le journal
des débats
quel beau discours il a faim casimir
perier alors ça c'est drôle ça c'est
sérieux
et quelque chose
le monsieur du deuxième sur la rue
déménagé depuis quand depuis il a pas
laissé l'adresse monsieur les mouchards
s'il n'a pas touché à son déjeuner
monsieur n'a pas faim ça va très bien
merci
j'ai vu que monsieur n'a pas de poils
dans sa nouvelle chambre et il fait
froid mais si mais si ça va très bien
mais alors pourquoi avoir fait du feu
dans ma chambre
parce que tu fais une femme et cinq
doivent avoir foi certains hommes bruits
faisaient oui terre carottes de
pensionnaires tuléar mettra ses
déguisements non par exemple j'espère
vite je ne remettrai jamais ses erreurs
là avec ses chapeau sur la tête j'ai
l'air de me lâcher un fou moi père
retourneront au luxembourg
non
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il veut c'est imbécile
pourquoi est ce qui vient tourner flairé
examiné essayé
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent une amourette
une aventure
et moi moi
quoi j'aurais été d'abord le plus
misérable des hommes et puis le plus
malheureux
j'aurais fait 60 ans de ma vie sur les
où devrait s'ouvrir de ce qu'on peut
sourire
j'aurais pays sans avoir été jeunes je
répétais sans famille sans par 100
femmes 100 jean jaurès edmond censure
poupe les pierres sur toutes les poses à
toutes les bornes de l'ong tous les murs
j'ai retrouvé cette petite fille j'en
aurais fait toute ma vie
et voilà au moment où je suis récompensé
au moment où c'est fini ou c'est bon
c'est bien j'ai payé j'ai gagné à voir
qui vient belle
et tout s'en va
tous ces batteries je perds cosette je
perds ma vie je perds mon âme parce
qu'il a pu un imbécile de venir se
promener au luxembourg 20 ans de bagne
20 ans de bagne pour avoir volé un pain
jean valjean pour vol avec effraction la
nuit dans une maison habitée cinq ans de
galère affaire suivante émondeurs fait
drôle chez rien de plus et monde aurait
fait drôle
rien d'autre la chair est cette enfant
pas d'argent pas de pain à la lettre pas
de pain au bout de quatre ans première
évasion repli en août deux jours trois
ans 5 et 3 8 2e et baston manquent à
l'appel de retrouver sous la quille d'un
bateau en construction résiste aux
gardes chiourmes évasion rébellion cinq
ans dont deux double chaîne 13 ans
troisième évasion quatre heures de
liberté
sept ans pour ces quatre heures total 20
ans pour avoir volé un pain
[Musique]
alors jean valjean juge à la société la
condamnation il se déclare à lui même
qu'il n'y avait pas équilibre entre le
dommage qu'il avait causé le dommage
qu'on lui causait il était entré au
bagne un homme triste et ignorants il en
sortit la rage au ventre et la haine au
coeur on lui remit son pécule résultat
de son travail de vingt années il se
montait à 100 9 francs 15 shu
[Musique]
voilà m'appelle jean valjean jeu
galériens libéré depuis quatre jours
destination pontarlier fait dans une
auberge on m'a chassé à cause de mon
passeport jaune dans une autre m'a dit
vas t'en la prison n'a pas voulu de moi
je suis allé dans la liste dressée il
m'a mordu mais j'ai de l'argent je peux
payer
je suis fatigué j'ai fait aujourd'hui
j'ai fait mon boulot je reste mais vous
ne mettrez ok mais c'est pas tout ça
vous avez entendu je suis galériens je
viens des galères j'ai un passeport
jaune je sais lui en moi regardez cet
homme dangereux
j'avais entendu le fait qu elle mettra
guedra au lit de l'alcool et attentes et
nous vous laissons mode argent mon mari
est ici c'est vous monsieur vous
partageraient bien notre souper
alors décidément vous mélangez c'est
chez vous trois zones j'avais bien
réfléchi
qu'est ce qui vous dit que je prenais
c'est simple c'est une affaire entre
dieu et vous soyez vous même refus de la
soupe et du fromage
[Musique]
monseigneur sarr mois reste à charge
il avait l'air de fuir et nous avons
trouvé sept argenterie sur lui
voilà je suis bien l'âge de vous voir
vous avez donné aussi les chandeliers
qui sont en argent comme le reste est de
vous pouviez avoir 200 francs pourquoi
devloo pas emporté avec les couverts
mais vous pouvez le laisser aller sachez
le
parce que c'est vrai comme le dollar ou
chandeliers pour les laits et n'oubliez
pas n'oubliez jamais que vous m'avez
jurés et ample et cet argent à devenir
honnête si c'est votre âme que j'en
achète on raconte que cette même nuit du
5 octobre 1815
le voiturier qu'ils faisaient à cette
époque le service de grenoble et qui
arrivait à digne vers 3 heures du matin
vie en traversant la place de l'évêché
un homme à genoux sur le pavé dans
l'ombre devant la porte de l'évêque
je
[Musique]
à
1820 un homme fait la fortune de
montreuil sur mer
arrivé dans le vêtement la tournure et
le langage d'un ouvrier trois ans plus
tard il était riche et mieux il avait
fait tous riches autour de lui monsieur
madeleine avait 50 ans l'air préoccupé
et bon c'est tout ce qu'on pouvait en
dire il était devenu maire il avait
fondé deux usines ou quiconque se
présentait pouvait trouver du travail à
condition d'être de moeurs honnête mais
un homme restaient obstinément rebelles
à la fascination qu'exerçait monsieur
madeleine
il s'appelait javert c'était un
inspecteur de police une physionomie
étrange et javert se disaient qu'est ce
que c'est que cet homme là je les ai
déjà vus quelque part six mois six mois
de prison
mais connaître qu'est ce qu'elle va
devenir ma fille aussi l'inspecteur
javert jauzion le podium j'ai pas eu
tort c'est ce qu'on voit que ce n'est
même pas une amie de la neige dans le
dos il tenait des raisons tels actes qui
disait t'as pas dedans et moi j'étais
honnête avec l'egypte parlait pas alors
il mène la neige dans le dos et lui
demanderait pardon
j'étais trop vive je n'ai pas dit aminé
ce chef au chapeau
mais je vous en prie monsieur j'avais
fait ma grasse pour aujourd'hui
j'avais en prison bien que cette super
chaud je vais vous dire c'est pour ma
petite fille est alors nourri chez les
thénardier montfermeil près de paris
senard dié des aubergines des p o
sa part des gens là ça fait de l'argent
voyez vous c'est une petite la lettre
est à même la dorure blagueur divers
je vous en supplie mettez pas en prison
y avait un débat au brésil vous plaire
les six mois non inspecteur j'avais
c'était gai mais c'est une mère
[Applaudissements]
d'arrêter
l'inspecteur javert remettez cette femme
en liberté liberté liberté c'est lui qui
l'avait dit mme sheila bair c'est bien
vous que je fasse pas mais six mois
qu'elle puisse payer
vous devez beaucoup d'argent quelque
part at war vous avez dit vous avez
clavier cracher à la figure
ce monstre il m'a chassée de son usine à
vos attaques gueule qui voulaient ragots
à l'atelier parce que les filles c'est
une honte
mettre à la rue une fille qui fait
correctement son travail qu'il fait
honnêtement touché le poil ça me prend
pendant
puisqu'on va lui demanda les charges
envoyé passe à droite sur l'a6 à ce que
vous allez là le savez moi monsieur le
maire sait pas pourquoi cette
malheureuse et insulté un bourgeois
je me suis informé pendant que vous
aimiez cette femme au poste c'est le
bourgeois qui est homo sapiens l'insulté
monsieur le maire cela me regarde ça
regarde la justice écoutez jaber cette
femme ne fera pas un seul jour de prison
le fait dont vous parlez est en fait de
police municipale en vertu des articles
9 11 15 et 66 du code d'instruction
criminelle
je suis seul juge je vous ordonne de
remettre cette femme en liberté
monsieur le maire sortait
je ne savais pas ce que vous avez dit je
ne savais pas qu'on vous avez chassé de
l'atelier ne vous allez vous soyez vous
aurez votre fille près de vous j'irai la
chercher à montfermeil
je vous le jure
[Musique]
monsieur le maire je vous ai dénoncé
dénoncé la préfecture de police de paris
comme mère ayant empiété sur la police
comme ancien forçat que vous prenez pour
un nommé jean valjean que j'ai vue à
toulon en 1801 força qui a volé un
évêque à sa sortie du bagne huit ans
qu'on le cherche
moi je m'étais figuré alors je vous ai
dénoncé et que vous attend répondu que
j'étais fou et alors on avait raison il
faut bien puisque le véritable jean
valjean ai trouvé qu est ce que vous
dites
on va juger nos méchants mathieu un
vagabond très misérables arrêté pour vol
de pommes transféré de saint-omer la
prison d'arras là dessus un ancien
compagnon de chêne brevets la
reconnaître je suis leur pays on
convoque et alors et alors je les
reconnais monsieur n'est formellement
reconnu j'ai bien lu il a beau nier
c'est jean valjean comprend pourquoi il
n'y il ya récidive vol de pommes pour un
four ça c'est un crime et puis à
l'histoire de l'évêque
il aurait volé une pièce de 40 sous un
petit savoyard est bon pour toulon et la
faire se juge prend demain
en somme il suffirait de laisser faire
tu as trouvé un remplaçant
ce javert qui ne cherchent toujours en
arrêt devant toi le voit la déroute est
absolument dépister il le tient son jean
valjean tué sauver tu entends sauver et
bien cet homme va aux galères c'est vrai
mais que dire qu'il a volées volées et
si tu restes ici toi si tu continues
dans dix ans tu as gagné 10 millions
tulle et répand dans le pays tu n'as
rien à toi mais qu'est ce que ça fait ce
n'est pas pour toi tu travailles c'est à
cause de toi que tu où prospèrent ici
que les gens sont heureux que la misère
disparaît avec elle la débauche la
prostitution le vol tous les vices tous
les crimes
tu es madeleine reste madeleine monsieur
madeleine tout le monde te le demande ne
cède pas après tout ce voleur de pommes
il a sûrement mérité les galères pour
autre chose
monsieur le président monsieur le maire
mais j'ai le président fait moins
arrêter l'homme que vous cherchez n'est
pas sans mathieu c'est moi je suis jean
valjean jean valjean fut condamné aux
travaux forcés à perpétuité le 25
juillet 1823
fantine était morte le 20 octobre de la
même année il s'évadait à nouveau du
bagne de toulon
c'est lorsque tu portes la télé j'étais
sa tempe cieux et qui vient de loin
classe sur ce qu'est dans le bois et tu
vas loin un bon quart d'heure d'ici
j'ai donc pas demain je sais pas je
crois pas les autres en ont moi j'en ai
pas je crois que je n'en ai jamais eu
comment t'appelles-tu cossette
j'habite chez madame thénardier
m'appelle l'alouette
il n'y ait pas de cerveau lancé il ya
moi seul au nom yen mais cette terre des
expos ninea telma qu'est-ce qu'ils font
rien qu'à moi je travail se penchera
près de la maison faudra mais c'est pas
le saut mais pourquoi parce que je suis
madame pas comme la porte et elle battra
écoute causette on va aller voir madame
thénardier monsieur thénardier ensemble
et puis on leur dira que je t'emmène et
puis ce sera fini tu entends fini tu
vivre avec moi tu n'auras plus jamais ni
fin ni froid tu comprends et valjean
emmena causette avec lui fantine devait
100 francs ou thénardier valjean compta
case 100 franprix de causette par la
main et disparus pour tout le monde sauf
pour javert javert n'avait jamais cessé
de poursuivre dans la halle jean un
forçat et vanessa se retrouvent ils
avaient retrouvé à paris six mois plus
tard
[Applaudissements]
déjà vers fait une faute il laissa aller
son homme devant lui sachant qu'il le
tenait
mais désirant reculé le plus possible le
moment de l'arrêter heureux de le sentir
priés de le voir libre avec cette
volupté du chat qui laisse courir la
souris achats semoir meute mais quel
délice que c'était tout venant
on ne prie pas si tu gris c'est uber la
thénardier la quête elle vient pendre à
bruz
moi
perthois le dos au mur vite
chochotte
c'est un jardin n'y a pas du tout
hauteur c'est le latéral et ben il est
dépassé par la région juste avant est
fouillé l'argent la rue droite
liferay typique fait j'aurais pas qu'il
y ait les recherches furent qu'inutile
javert ségara dans les terrains vagues
d'alentour jean valjean et est tombé
dans un couvent il réussit à s'y cacher
à s'y faire recevoir en tant que
jardinier sous le nom de fauche le vent
les religieuses étaient des recluses il
fut un reclus au couvent était joint une
institution pour l'éducation des jeunes
filles cosette il fut admise
elle fut le frasil faucheux 20 les
années passèrent cosette grandissait et
insensiblement valjean ce mythe a adoré
cosette ce vieux coeur qui avaient tous
subi tout supporter mais qui était 9ème
1 il est ma cause est comme sa fille et
comme sa mère et il les mains comme sa
soeur et comme il n'avait eu ni amende
ni épouse comme la nature est une
créancières qui n'accepte aucun protêt
ce sentiment là aussi le plus imperdable
de tous fut mêlé aux autres inconscients
pur de la pureté de l'ameublement et
l'amour proprement diffus dans sa
tendresse immense pour cause est comme
le filon d'or et dans la montagne
ténébreux et vierge au bout de sept ans
il jugea que le monde autour de lui
devait l'avoir oublié et qu'il était
temps d'y revenir
il décida de quitter le couvent il
n'avait oublié qu une chose qu aux aides
pouvait devenir belle
cause est hyper il ya bien longtemps
consomment partons au luxembourg le
thuya les mains howie père enfin si vous
voulez bien
qu'est ce que tu as tu es triste non
t'es tu veux partir oui
allons-nous ça si tu veux ne rien
lendemain non pas la paix ne soit voix
mantel se veut un rêve que la tonne de
la dahlberg et il attaque et que ce soit
la dizaine de sans sucre lui abritera on
la saisit oublier l'ami ans casse le
goût à vivre le levier d'un décor ni la
botte praticable l'ecclésiaste a dit
validé et tout est validé ben moi je
pense comme symbole grpn jamais existé
ça c'est grand terrain t'aime bien mais
tu nous en dire tu t'en vas
autrefois quand je ne sais pas
les gangs sont venus et l'ont d'antenne
quoi servent à des bulls a débuté
oh
attrait bienfaisante marquise
décrocherait à gaza 2009
on me suis bien fait ce genre dans
l'église de saint jacques duhault pas
après
que voulez vous mademoiselle une lettre
pour vous monsieur marius fille aînée
vous dira que nous sommes sans un
morceau de pain depuis deux jours quatre
personnes et mon épouse malade si je
suis si je suis plus déçu dans ma pensée
je crois devoir respect que votre coeur
généreux s'humanise race est exposé et
vous subjuguera désir de mettre propice
en déniant le premier est né j'ai bien
fait j'entrais oui on est gendre est vos
voisins l'autre côté du mur un miroir et
des livres vous savez que je sais lire
le général baudoin reçu l'ordre
d'enlever avec cinq bataillons la
redoute de au gaumont qui est au milieu
de la plaine de waterloo ou waterloo je
connais ça c'est une bataille dans les
temps mon père l'était les rues de man
bonaparte estime ses grosses roues les
anglais waterloo je sais écrire me
croyais pas vous voulez voir n'est laid
comme mieux sont là c'est pas faute hein
j'ai reçu d'éducation
on n'a pas toujours été comme ça on
était parfaite
à
savez-vous monsieur marius que vous êtes
jolis garçons on ne fait pas attention à
moi mais je vous connais moi monsieur
marius je vous ai rencontrés dans
l'escalier sur le boulevard ça vous va
très bien aux cheveux ébouriffés
permettez moi de vous dire m ce qu on a
pu aller chercher ma soeur et moi et
c'est vous qui les avez trouvés sur le
boulevard c'est ma soeur qui les a
perdus alors on rentre on a rien dit on
a dit qu'on les avait portés qu'on nous
avait des knicks parce qu'on ne voulait
pas être battu
parce que c'est inutile c'est absolument
inutile alors vous les avez lu qu'est ce
que vous voulez c'est comme ça quand on
est pauvre on n'a pas le choix
tiens c'est celle pour le vieux qui va à
la messe cela lui porte et tout de suite
il nous donnera peut-être de quoi
déjeuner savez vous ce que ça fera cent
des jeunes aujourd'hui ça fera qu'on
aura une autre des jaunes et
d'avant-hier notre dîner d'avant-hier
notre déjeuner d'hier notre dîner d'hier
tout ça d'un coup ce matin
si vous n'êtes pas content quand les
chiens
des fois le soir je m'en vais des fois
je ne rentre pas l'année dernière on
habitait sous les ponts jali tout seul
je dormais dans les fossés savez-vous la
nuit quand je marche sur le boulevard je
vois les arbres comme des péniches et
maisons sont grosses comme notre dame et
ses toiles sont des lampions en tira une
fête
j'entends les orgues de barbarie et les
mécaniques des filatures est ce que je
sais moi je crois qu'on jette des
pierres je me sauve en courant
tout tourne tout tourne quand on n'a pas
mangé on est drôle
chaque fois tu luisant un monarque dans
cette poule
vous êtes un bon million de jours de
croûtes et la viande moche et du fric
hautes marées qu'est ce qu'on va se
mettre
bonjour monsieur c'est égal j'ai trouvé
mon vieux c'est bon c'est dur ça passe
mais dans je m'appelle eponine
la vertu des clémence et piété et celles
qui n'utilisent étroitement la société
promenez votre sentiment chrétien est
fait en regard de compassion surinam
fortunés famille je mangerai mans vous
voyez l amitié lise érables et genou
montreux les certificats trapu et ça
mange trois fois par jour
petite amie calme toi te fait pas de mal
tu es trop bon d'écrire à tous ces gens
là mon homme
et bien qu'ils somment le vieux lévis
saint jacques tout de suite il me suis
livré via core77 pers
c'est sur ces lieux où il a du mal être
ouais doucement un bonhomme ségala
optical up
oui il a lu la lettre en sortant de
l'église il est avec sa fille je lui ai
dit je vais vous menez il m'a dit non
nous viendrons tout à l'heure tu as des
maladresses alors je lui ai donné
alors comment tu sais qu'il arrive j'ai
vu le fiacre qui tournait la rue dupetit
banquier jacques avaler tu attends le
sien à paris et que je vois des pailles
à faire des bonnes choses
il fait 3 3 pc à bas les huit voix
brouillée un peu sympa 45 des coûts je
suis fait mal d'envieux à les rappeurs
c'est très bien toi aussi tu es mal il
est complètement dérangé l'apec
l'entente la paire
vous trouverez dans ce paquet des
vêtements débats et des couvertures de
laine
donc on les mon bienfaiteur c'est trop
c'est trop
regarde ma femme d'une ips à l'occasion
j'ai enfin vu d'yvette aequo avec celui
là à terre à construire et à la fois une
joie de vous avoir est une honte
ma route je suis un ancien artiste
dramatique monsieur et qui a eu du
succès fab en tout élève de talma je
suis un élève de talma monsieur et quand
je me vois ici ça sansfaçon pam ma femme
malade le carreau cassé ma petite fille
blessée
regardez la belle demoiselle est un
accident qui est arrivé en travaillant
sur une mécanique pour 6 ou par jour
si ce monsieur tout ce que vous avez
monsieur second tour
aia
rien si c'est la fin des trois jours de
non plus une balle nous n'avons
plusieurs sous monsieur ma femme a les
étouffements c'est son âge et puis le
système d'armes s'en est mêlé pas
d'argent et pourtant j'élève mes filles
dans la religion est pas voulu qu'elle
fasse eta je ne badine pas bref je leurs
flancs des besoins sur l'honneur la m'en
allais la vertu moi je j'entends les
éduqués comme il faut et sa soirée
n'était que ça soit gentil et que ça
croit en dieu sacré nom voilà le terme
fier de moi c'est le 15 je dois une
année 63 membres bienfaiteurs 4 terme
aux retards
si je ne paie pas si c'est la rue sous
la pluie sous la neige voilà
merci je n'ai que cet argent aurait sur
moi mais mais mais je reviendrai ce soir
vous apporter les 60 francs qui vous
renverra compagnie merci merci mon
bienfaiteur mon bienfaiteur mon
bienfaiteur mon auguste bienfaiteur
souffre et que je vous reconduis jusqu'à
votre fracture
je passe avant tout et je vous suis en
remontant va dire une chose qui va bien
et pathé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
blessé à l'oeil il ya davance mais
espérons rentrant monsieur rigole à lui
j'ai fait mon père par deux fricot
geffroy ma mère pas de tricot gros lot
la sanglante chapeau vous rentrez du
d'orange il aime c'est marius vous êtes
vous allez attraper du mal et coacher
pour me tutoyez moi je préfère j'ai vu
ton père avec un homme et sa fille ils
parlaient ensemble c'est toi qui les a
menés oui tu sais leur adresse non
trouve à moi c'est ça que vous voulez
c'est ça vous les connaissez non
c'est à dire que vous ne la connaissez
pas et que vous voulez la connaître
qu'est ce que vous me donnerez ce que tu
voudras
vous aurez l'adresse banquier lui et que
je les reconnais même taille
un village à peine plus vieux il est
mieux mythe si tout allait du lot au
dehors tout de suite avec sa mallette
bombe allait y aller d'or il toucherait
la petite idée reçue n
c'est pas possible mais suivant toute
nue ellen police de satin chapeau de
velours à saint frusquin d'au moins 200
francs c'est pas la même c'est elle je
te dis mais torres est le regardais mes
filles avec pitié 7,2
je voudrais lui crever avoir à coups de
pied
je vais dire encore une chose c'est que
ma fortune et fait tonner ça fait assez
longtemps je suis parfois c'est la
paroisse mère de fascicules effet
meurent de froid si tu as du pin vers
les as et lui la misère je ne plaisante
pas un trou plus aqesss connais moi
maintenant j'en à savoir à m'asseoir
dormir sachant tour avant de crever tout
est millionnaire comme tout le monde
qu'est ce que tu veux dire parce que je
veux dire écoute
il est brisé c'est comme si c'était fait
je vais voir qu'il faut pas trop me net
le philanthrope revient à 9h effet née
la mer bureau n'est plus là voisin dinan
ville et range amelle 11 heures il ya
personne dans la maison
les petites fourmis y est tu nous aidera
il s'exécutera ci s'exécute pas on lui
de lectra bon je sors encore laissé
pousser mais pas ma jolie petite barbe
romantique qui m'avait reconnu il serait
pardonnée tu as bien riche en charbon de
bois
ouais bon alors tu achèteras elle de
bois sur le charbon est actuellement
drechou un grand feu bien fort et tu
connais une quincaillerie en quartiers
au coin de la rue mouffetard est d'abord
allé voir brûlures
c'est un bon celui des leurs
[Musique]
la thur de tout seul
bien sûr puisque je venais chan dans un
corridor connaissez la maison un peu
ancienne propriété gourbault 50 52 y
avait eu la thrombine est là sous j'ai
entendu prononcer ce mois là montcornet
ce clash ou le média rejoint mauvais
pour jean et il a dit qu'il allait
devoir
hu
barak on peut pas se cacher sa
n'apercevoir et les commandera le
vaudeville sont si modestes le public de
dérange vous avez un pass pour la nuit
oui tu avais moi on va tourner la balle
observez bien laisser un peu aller et
comment juger avec la chose et murs car
un coup de pistolet l'important au
plafond le reste me regarde mais surtout
attendait qu'il y ait un commencement
d'exécution
cet avocat vous savez ce que ça veut
dire à propos si vous avez besoin de
madison avenue ou envoyés ici je
m'appelle jamais
il est l'heure
les filles f anglais
c'est ce qu'il faut pas ici des chaises
pour quoi faire
pour s'asseoir je cherchais celle de
voisins la tai shen
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
meneur sénat trois ans qui craque fais
moi plaisir des sens de l'attendre à
devant la porte qui précédera dans
l'escalier a les bras
le bienfaiteur en mode fiac
monsieur fabre voici vos 80 francs pour
le loyer un peu plus nous verrons par la
suite que de merci monsieur que de mercy
s'ils voudront
et comment va la petite blessé au mal
très mal m'en dit monsieur s'assure
normes et à l'hôpital se faire pensez
vous les verrez tout à l'heure et madame
fait bon ton
l agonie mais vous les voulez tant de
courage monsieur cette feria stade à
l'honneur le siège principal à kauda
elle faisait de mal à personne mais
si j'étais le gouvernement ça ne se
passera pas comme ça tenez j'ai voulu
faire apprendre le métier de cartes aux
nières méfie car thonière vous vous
rendez compte qu'elle dégradation pour
un homme qui a été peintre oui mon cher
bienfaiteur jeu et eco médias mais
surtout j'étais peintre
j'étais très doux et vous savez il ne
reste rien de tout ça rien sauf une
chose à quoi je tiens un tableau dont
joue est forcé de me défaire parce qu'il
faut vivre
piszczek tombe l'homme ça c'est ton
voisin et travaille dans une usine de
produits chimiques à côté ne fait pas
attention
qu'est ce que je disais donc je disais
que j'avais un tableau à vendre notre
ami de la maison qu'ils habitent tous
ici que remettre un tableau inestimable
j'y tiens comme un défi ça me rappelle
des souvenirs
mais je vous le vend mon bienfaiteur à
vous je vais bien le vendre je ne le
vendrai trop cher pas cher
à combien estimez vous avez vous votre
portefeuille je me contenterai de 10 x
1000 francs
mais si mais si vous n'achetez pas ce
tableau j'ai plus qu'à me jeter à la
rivière moi mes filles après le
cartonnage
il faut une table il faut un fourneau un
pot à trois compartiments pour la colle
entre enchères un moule en art taux des
prêts sont tout ça pour gagner quatre
sous par jour et on travaille 14h04 sous
par jour
comment voulez vous qu'on vive il faut
se tuer j'ai descendu l'autre jour 3
mars pour ça du côté du pont
d'austerlitz et puis ne s'agit pas
est-ce que vous me reconnaissez tout est
prêt oui vraiment parnasse le jeune
premier s'est arrêté pour cause et
pauline la voiture en bas avec des
chevaux il me reconnaissais pas non je
m'appelle pas fait bon retour je
m'appelle pas joe drake
je m'appelle thénardier je suis
l'auberge de montfermeil vous m'entendez
thénardier vous me reconnaissez
maintenant par des montages fumée
flambée rica cif à la crapaudine je vous
retrouve enfin monsieur le philanthrope
vieujot crise non c'est pas vous qui est
devenu il ya huit ans a confirmé dans
mon auberge c'est pas vous qui avez
emmené chez moi l'enfant de la fente in
l'alouette et bien je vous reconnais moi
je sais reconnu tout de suite quand vous
êtes tenir pour fait l'envié n'y est de
méchante couverture d'hôpital voleurs
d'enfants
avec son héros bonasse vous êtes bien
moqué de moi c'est vous qui est la cause
de tous les malheurs
vous savez le port 15 100 francs une
fille qui était certainement un des
riches et dont j'aurais dû dire et de
quoi vivre toute ma vie mais aujourd'hui
c'est moitié la tour vous êtes foutu mon
bonhomme nous me lever et ils tombent
dans le panneau et fluidique je suis
acteur et je lui dis je suis peintre et
que soit le terme
thiam c'est en janvier et on est en
février
imbécile absurde crétins
je tenais je les fasse ce matin je te
mangerais le coeur ce soir je ne vois
pas ce que vous voulez dire je ne suis
pas millionnaire vous me prenez pour un
autre à la bonne balle euros soit au nom
vous dit n'est décidément on va vous
pataugez mon vieux alors vous vous ne
voyez pas qui je suis vous êtes un
bandit bouge pas toi il ose appeler
comme ça les gens riches tiens c'est
vrai j'ai fait faillite je me cache j'ai
plus de pages et plus où je suis un
bandit
j'ai pas mangé depuis trois jours tu as
morny vous vous chauffez les pieds vous
avez des redingotes souhaitez vous loger
au premier dans les maisons rapportiez
vous mangez des truffes ont mangé des
asperges à 30 francs au mois de janvier
et qu'on voulait savoir s'il fait froid
vous vous regardez dans le journal
combien il fait au thermomètre
nous chez nous qui sont les thermomètres
et vous voulez dans nos cavernes we know
cavernes nous happer bandits mais nous
vous mange on dort petit nous vous
dévoilerons qu'on se pose qui osent
venir me parler comme un sac et et
sachez bien ceci je ne suis pas un homme
louche moi je suis un ancien soldat
français que vrai que des clans est jeté
à vacallo moi j'ai sauvé le soldat
français en général français il m'a dit
son nom mais j'ai rien compris
simplement j'ai entendu mr ces gens elle
préfère autre chose et ce tableau là
vous savez pas partir et était pas par
david à bruxelles et mon représentant
toi
bon ben maintenant ça suffit
faut de l'argent beaucoup d'argent
énormément d'argent je vous exterminer
tonnerre de dieu
alors qu'est ce que tu as dit rencontre
met en chantier
est ce que tu as à rire toi j'ai le
droit non oui c'est pas mal oui heures
rien pas portefeuille par le montre pas
l'argent il est rude saviola attaché le
ok dit pourquoi tu ont amené temps
c'était pas utile la saison une mauvaise
foi d'affaires ont tous voulu en être
vous avez eu tort de la sauter par la
fenêtre
vous auriez pu casser les jambes est-ce
que vous avez seulement marqué vous avez
pas pousser leurs écrits pas le moindre
au secours mon lieu où vous auriez un
peu crié à l'assassin j'aurai pour
trouver ça inconvenant ça se dit à
l'occasion on vous aurait même pas
bâillonner d'ailleurs et je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que cet endroit si
est très discret la pièce est très sourn
el aqsa pour elle mêle ici le tonnerre
frais boom il canon ferai plus en somme
vous n'avez pas intérêt à voir la police
débarquer ici
abbas et tout comme nous on peut donc
s'entendre bien quand j'ai été très
exagérées tout à l'heure je suis laissé
aller à des extrémités dont dont je
m'excuse auprès de vous par exemple
parce que vous êtes millionnaire jeudi
qu'il fallait énormément d'argent
j'étais pas résonnent on a beau et riche
on a déjà eu une première en convenir
tenez je veux y mettre du mien je me
contenterai de 200 mille francs
comme dirigé par deux cent mille francs
sur moi je pouvais pas prévoir c'est
l'évidence alors vous allez avoir la
volonté de décrire ce que je vais vous
dictez je vous préviens que je ne
mettrai pas que vous ne sachiez prêt à
écrire
comment voulez-vous j'écrive je suis
attaché à on devient raisonnable délier
la main droite de monsieur gerry vite ma
fille non mais t'es ma chère fille vient
sur le champ où j'ai absolument besoin
de toi
la personne était chargé de ramener à
moi aller
mademoiselle fabre chez monsieur urbain
fabre rue saint-dominique d'enfer il
sait aller qu'ils n'oublient pas que ça
vaut 200 mille francs aux gens à
l'échelle
[Applaudissements]
monsieur fabre autant je vous le dise
tout de suite afin de parvenir avec
votre fille elle revenir tout seul
parce qu'elle aura fait un petit détour
avant et l'aurait mis votre fille à
l'abri ne font pas mal simplement on va
la garder au frais et ne vous aurais
donné les deux cent mille francs on vous
la rendre à et si vous faites le méchant
si vous vous obstinez à quelqu'un là-bas
qui donnera le coup de pouce à
l'alouette iii j ça vous soyez prévenus
[Applaudissements]
fonds s'adresse à des mini personnes au
numéro 17 mesures bafa attendu monsieur
clavier ce vieux t'as déposé moi j
aurais couper le lagon est en quête pour
commencer par la question tous les jours
il revient celle qui valide qu'elle est
la fille qu'il aime à go west eux les
hommes sont bêtes destinées non pourquoi
pour gagner du temps il tient encore
faire une pâte ils s'ennuient
rapprochement répond chez moi qu'il est
ficelé vous avez créé vous ne feriez
parler comme fourier écrire ce que je
voulais pas écrire tonné
et maintenant face claude rey n'a plus
qu'une chose à faire l'escarpelle
[Musique]
l'école sont là c'est l'écriture
d'eponine tout le monde à la fenêtre
battu par m ennuie pas le temps
l'échec est ce que jaffer
d'après l'oim après il nous plaît pas
allez vous meyrals sont là alors on tire
au sort
mais vous êtes fous à la coupe pas est
peut-être pour mettre les noms d'alain
bonnet voulez mon chapeau passerait pas
par la fenêtre ne passerait pas la porte
c'est moi malsain vous êtes 8 nous
sommes 15 on ne va pas se colleter comme
des auvergnats faille aujourd'hui
messieurs dont couvent arrêté
qu'est ce que je te disais labrosse
posters ou y pousse à tout le monde
délié monsieur mes filles membres
bonjour jean bie grenaille
bonjour goemaere babey 2 milliards
d'actions en somme il demande que
montparnasse tout patron mines et hénin
à
quel va être le meilleur
[Musique]